zach playsack he will be the northeast
ohio ford dealers starting pitcher
tonight
please sack six and four on a year 464
earned run average
you know 85 and a third innings struck
out 52 giving up 16 home runs and you
can see his career against the tigers
very good
three and one with a you know doesn't
even give up a run a game so they're
going to need that from him
akil badu the rookie left fielder will
start it off today
and please set got him with guess what a
change-up man that's what
eli morgan had him flailing away at eric
highs
he's d.h today so we're gonna miss
he strikes out that'll end the inning
please sack k's a pair
indians will be facing right-hander
willie peralta making his 11th
appearance
and 10th start did not factor in the
decision in the
4-2 tigers win on tuesday but just gave
up just the one run against a really
good
boston red sox lineup and that'll bring
up jose ramirez switch header batting
left-handed
the pitch swung on line to left field
that's a base hit
it'll get near the line over to cut it
off padau but ramirez still going for
two
in with a head first slide and the
double is his 21st
puts an indian in scoring position no
score in the first for fran mill race
there's a line driving a base hitting
the right field ramirez around third
grossman's throw not in time
one-nothing cleveland from reyes
delivers
with a two-out rbi single and the
indians are up one to nothing
back walks set some real rarity for zach
please act
here's the three tune delivery
a swing and a mess got him with a change
up down and in
griner is out number two strikeout
number three
tigers had two on nobody out now it's
two on two out looking for a big hit
from derek hill it's one nothing indians
win the second inning the 2-2
swinging a high fly ball left center
field this one's got some carry to it in
left center off the top of the wall
and go on a home run or is it third base
umpire greg gibson says home run that's
a three-run
shot for derrick hill first career home
run gives the tigers a 3-1 lead in the
second
and man hits his first home run of his
career how about that
bottom of his second inning indians down
three to one and owen miller leads off
high fly ball deep center field back his
hill he's out of room and
it is out of here the indians come right
back oh and miller's second home run of
the year
makes it a one-run game at 3-2
sharply to third oh and they drop it at
second base
clement took his eye off it scope takes
advantage all the way to third
that was an inning ending double play
probably runners at the corners big
opportunity here opens the door for
jamer candelario who walked and scored
that one bounces away from hedges here
comes scope
he scores easily the tigers are up 4-2
1-1 on jamer candelario do some damage
right here though the 1-1 swinging the
line driving to left-center field
slicing
it's going to get by mercado deep into
the left-center field gap
hospital score candelario liking it to
second throw not in time
rbi double for jamer candelario and the
tigers have a 5-2 lead here in the third
gee thanks a lot i appreciate the
confidence here's the 2-2 to straw
and nice pitch by willie peralta his
first strikeout of the day gets straw
looking
after getting nicked for a run in the
first to run in the second and the
tigers giving him that 5-2 lead he wants
to come out here against the top of the
order and just slam the door on him
he strikes out zimmer as well zimmer
thought it was up
paul clemons the home plate umpire said
it was in the zone two away
jose ramirez had a two out double in the
first
peralta strikes out the side down go the
indians
one two three the indians have a
one out base runner chopped in the hole
short throws it away mercato on his way
to third
oh and miller up he'll go to second and
after a wide turn oscar will hold at
third base so at defensive miscue
as the indians knocking on the door
trying to claw their way back in it here
in the fourth inning zach short with a
terrific stop
he unloaded in a hurry but obviously
that throw is wide of the mark
andreas jimenez will be the batter
in the air left field but due
makes the grab mercado will tag he will
score
and the indians close the gap to 5-3
give jimenez his sixth run batted in on
the air first
since rejoining the big league club now
austin hedges who bounced to third his
first time up
here's the one-two pitch swung on popped
him up shallow right
center and that's gonna fall in for a
base hit
scoring on the play as miller gives
hedges an rbi and pulls the indians to
within a run
and now he's at first base for ernie
clement
drill deep left field ernie clements got
another hit this one's going for extra
bases again and coming around third
austin hedges are going to wave him home
here comes the tying run throw to the
plate he's safe
ernie goes to third on the throw his
fifth hit in the series his fourth
double of the year
ernie clement with rbi number five
and the indians have scored three times
here in the fourth to tie the ball game
we may need an oxygen tank down here if
you guys can get to one give him time
call timeout he needs to get it real
good pitching by shaw here
1-1 grounded fair down the first base
line and into the corner
grossman will dig for second he's got
himself a stand-up two-out double here
in the seventh
and that'll bring up the d8 jericho's
swing and a missy
struck him out chase ball four and haas
is hopping mad
stretch time in cleveland and the
indians again put the tie breaking run
on it first 5-5 game and bradley zimmer
one for three with a double
zimmer with a drive deep right field
there it goes goodbye bradley zimmer's
third home run of the season
a game changer here in the seventh and
the indians have come back from a 5-2
deficit and now they lead it
7-5 harold castro left-handed hitter
will pinch it and then stay in the game
and play short
blew it by him karachek strikes him up
the tigers go one two
three and the indians hold a two-run
edge going to the bottom of the e
the indians up seven to five in the
night
ground ball clement flags it down what a
play
a spinning throw on the move and on the
money one down he did that all in one
motion he didn't think about it he just
got it and
made the turn and made a pretty good
accurate throw
the tigers down to their last out high
puck on the infield ernie clement
calling for it
book it the indians take the series
winning two out of three as they close
about 7-5
the final today and with that win the
indians have clinched their sixth
consecutive winning season against the
tigers